Thanks hey everyone my name is Fred
Yaniv I work on the android framework
team and i'll be talking about android
printing how android puts pixels on
paper I'll be giving the talk with
Phillip my colleague he's going to join
us a bit later to talk about some more
tanks so you're probably already asking
yourself why printing matters in mobile
how is it important people are using
everything's in the cloud you don't need
to put physical paper it's outdated
technology well it turns out that the
main reason you want to add this print
into your applications is because your
users want it so there are some studies
that show that 95 percent of the
consumers and 67% of the corporate users
want to be able to print from mobile
applications which is a pretty strong
signal that printing is useful even from
mobile devices also some developers have
seen that if incorporating printing into
their app they get better retention they
have higher probability of in-app
purchases and the engagement of the
users is higher these are all great
examples but I also I also want to share
some of my personal experiences in why
mobile printing from mobile is important
for me and how it helped me for example
I'm always late for the airport oh is it
the last minute always running so what I
usually do is I log in on my device I
check in I print my boarding pass I run
to the airport because if my phone dies
when I'm checking in I have to go in
line again and I'm gonna miss my plane
so it's really really useful to be able
to print from mobile for me another
another use case that's really important
for me was I was recently refinance in
my house and my broker is always sending
me one more thing to sign it's very
important it has to be done now and of
course it's in the worst time when you
don't have computer next to you but we
have to we have printers all over campus
so I'm able to literally take my phone
out print to the closest printer sign
the paperwork take a photo and send it
so it was very very useful
and speaking about corporate
environments corporate printers more and
more companies have the policy of
bringing your own device and so in a
corporate environment printing is
definitely much more important than in
your personal everyday life so adding
printing Tauri application is definitely
adding more value to the user especially
in corporate environments so if you
remember printing on on on desktop it's
really really frustrating to set it up
working the first time you need to
download the right driver from the right
manufacturers it should be shoot for the
right model and if you want to do it
quickly it will really frustrate an
experience we just didn't want it you
want we wanted to not make the same
mistakes if you want to say that but try
something else instead in mobile and we
are working with the printing industry
to come up with a with the standards
that will work with printers from all
manufacturers so all big manufacturers
are members of the Moriya alliance you
can see all the familiar names that
probably you have printer at home from
one of these manufacturers so they came
to us and they said hey we wanna work
with you together to make printing much
easier for the user easier to set up
having a single piece of software that
can talk to printers from every
different manufacturer so the user
doesn't have to worry about setting up
their devices we also have members from
opera so they'll join us for Q&A at the
end and you'll be you have an
opportunity to touch base with them so
I'll be talking about the Android print
api's but before diving into that I want
to give you a very very brief view of
the Android print architecture so in in
mobile the question of what printers do
you have doesn't really make much sense
the real question is how many printers
can you find in my current context in my
current environment so the way undred
printing works is that you have
applications that want to print which is
what you guys work on that use the print
API you have print services so these are
the drivers if you want to think of them
as drivers so this is what our friends
from oprea
are working on and you have the system
which is the print manager that's the
main centralized brain that connects all
the dots and you have the print spooler
the print spooler is just a part that
shows the UI shows notifications shows
you the current print jobs and and
manages the current print jobs so that's
a high-level architecture of Android
without going too much details I'll go
straight to the ATIS the main thing I
want to show is how easy it is to print
from your app so how do you print from
application the first continue need to
do is to get a hold of the print manager
so there's our entry point for the print
framework it's very similar to how you
get the package manager activity manager
is very standard way of getting an
android standard service once you get
the print manager all you have to do is
call the print method you pass the print
job name and you pass a print document
adapter so the print document adapter is
the important part here so that's a
piece of the piece of software that
generates PDF based on what user is
selected in the UI such that it can
produce the printed content so before
actually before I go into the details
how you write the print document adapter
I want to briefly explain how was the
philosophy of printing on Android so
when you print we the application calls
into the system and says hey I want to
print and this is where a collaborative
process starts between the system and
the application to generate the content
based on the user constraints so what I
mean by that is for example user changes
the paper size so if the paper size is
different maybe your application one
wants to do a layout of two columns
instead of one column because you have
more space basically we want to
propagate all the constraints everything
the user has selected to the to the
applications so the application is in
the best position to lay out the content
the right way and render it I don't
think we changed was how we separated
layout
from rendering so layout is figuring out
how many pages you're going to have how
the content is going to be placed on the
pages and rendering is actually
producing the pixels from the layout the
reason we did this for example is if you
have a thousand page document you really
need to lay out the whole content to
know how many pages you have and what is
on page seven but if the user is looking
at page six and seven in the print
preview you don't want to render a
thousand pages because all you care is
rendering the two pages that the user
can see so this is why we have two
separate concepts of performing layout
and and rendering so so this is how the
layout callback looks on print document
adapter so it it provides you the print
attributes which is what the user has
selected in the UI and gives you a call
back to tell us when you're ready it's
completely synchronous it is call it
this API you can do any you can take any
amount of work but the shorter it takes
the better because this literally
affects the UX and when once you're
ready you can call back and say hey I'm
done I'm finished so here is information
about the document it has this many
pages and it's this type you can also
say hey I failed because of this reason
and the reason Citra the reason string
goes into DUI so the user knows what
happened and also another callback word
on the another callback is on Castle so
the castle tis if you notice the on
layout method takes a cancellation
signal and this is a way for the system
to nicely tell you hey please stop what
you're doing because things changed and
what you're doing is irrelevant so for
example if the user selects a page a
page size a4 and you start doing a
layout and the user changes in the
meantime the page size again we're
literally gonna ask me hey please stop
what you're doing because there is
different page size and you have to do
the work again so the more responsive
you are the better the user experiences
is so very similar to
lay out writing is very similar this is
very similar work in a very similar way
so we're telling you hey please render
these pages and we'll give you a page
range and we provide your destination so
write these pages in PDF format to this
file descriptor once you're ready you
again you get a callback and you can use
the callback to tell us hey I'm finished
and these are the pages that I that I've
written or you can say I fell because of
this reason which showed it we showed
this in the UI or you can say I was
cancelled so now now at this point
you're probably already saying wow this
is super complicated I don't want to
deal with all these callbacks this is
just all I want to do is print a photo
it should be very simple very easy I
don't need to do it all deal with all
these people complicated machinery and
and also you also think hey I don't know
anything about PDF I'm actually the same
I know almost nothing and I want to be
able to generate PDF content I don't
want to learn a PDF rendering library in
order to print very simple things and we
got you covered so we have a very simple
class that allows you to generate PDF
from from and from using standard
Android rendering commands so we realize
that you probably already know how to
put pixels on the screen and if you know
how to use the Android rendering API so
you can use the same approach to
generate PDF content and so the PDF
document class is the helper that does
that and the way it works is you create
a new PDF document you create a page
specification and you start the page
once you have the page this is where
there is interesting parties you can
literally get the canvas of the page and
you can render anything you like so in
this case I'm just getting a content
view which is just some view and asking
the view to draw itself on the canvas
and once you finish the rendering you're
saying hey finish the page and write the
document to this stream and that's it
you just generated PDF representation of
whatever rendering commands you issued
so it's pretty pretty easy
another another very useful facility we
have is being able to print bitmaps for
example is how you have a photo all you
want to do is put this photo to this
printer in few lines of code and the way
to do this is using the print helper
from the support library which is
dedicated for printing bitmaps to in a
backwards compatible fashion and the way
it works you create a print helper you
can specify some optional arguments for
example here we're saying hey we want to
print in color we want to print in
landscape and we want to scale the
content in a certain way and once you do
these small tweaks now we can literally
call the print method and pass a URI to
the bitmap and magic it just works so
the print helper takes care of all the
complicated machinery doing the oldest
callbacks doing layout doing writing and
everything is done for you for free
another very useful class another useful
facility for printing has been able to
print HTML because for example you want
to format text in a certain way and you
want to print it very easy way to format
text this HTML almost everybody knows
how to use HTML and what you can do is
you can format your text in HTML load it
in a web view that's pretty standard I'm
sure that most of you know how to do
this and once you do this web view has a
method which says hey create print
document adapter and this print document
adapter is the thing that you pass to
the print framework so once you get the
print document adapter from the web view
you can literally pass it to the print
manager sprint method it will it will
just work it will handle the layout the
the render the rendering and will do all
the cleanup it will do everything for
you it's very easy
so before I turn the microphone to
Philip
I just want to rehash that you can see
that we have very flexible API switch
which are very useful for very
sophisticated apps where you want to
control your layout and rendering very
well for example if you're an advanced
text editor you probably want to
implement the print document adapter
yourself because you have full control
how the layout is going to happen and
how what the output is going to be but
if you're an app developer that just
wants to put some pixels on the screen
you want to print a photo or you want to
print some formatted text or you want to
render something on instead of the
screen to render this to a PDF you can
use the older helper classes that I was
showing you so you can see that there is
there is there is an approach for
printing for everyone and we kind of
believe that using the role the the API
with the callbacks it's only for very
sophisticated use cases so with that I
will turn over to Phillip he's going to
be talking more about UX and how a
platform evolved over time thank you
thanks Matt um so we suit so easy this I
want to show you how the user interacts
with the print frame Brooke before
kitkat the only way you could print was
the absense out and intent with some
data and the printer manufacturers might
provide an app that receives this intent
and then renders the data onto the paper
the problem with that was that the
printing effectors app didn't know
anything about the content society
actual data and the result was sometimes
good but not always so we could get
reintroduced Oakland and collaborative
approach where the app the printer and
the user interact to create a print so
in my example here that you can see the
UI of KitKat and the printer provided
its properties for example what kind of
paper size it supports in my case letter
and I guess in my support I don't know
an eagle to the user can then select
which of the operative L often it wants
and then the app renders the result onto
the paper with lollipop we added the
preview which of course is very useful
to actually see what you're gonna print
before you actually put it on in the
physical world and also allows you very
easy to select which papers which pages
you don't want to print because you
might in my case five pages might be too
much I want to I don't want to want to
pay a print page three but marshmallow
there was no big changes we ended one
more capability so you can just you can
say which duplicates mode you want to
say but there most no major changes in
general there are no big changes between
KitKat all way to end for app developers
so if you write KitKat capable capable
code it will work or way to n so for n
we realized that the actual printing
workflow is quite nice now and it works
well but what doesn't work very well now
is the setup process of your printer so
in my example I set up a simple network
as everybody of us at home and put one
canon printer onto this network as I
guess it's a common use case can you
roll the video okay so I have my browser
open here and I want to print this page
so I select print and the print dialog
pops up and shows me a preview and it
says select printer ok I go ahead and
select your printer and I can save this
PDF but my plea doesn't show up yet so I
guess I have to edit so I press add
printer and it tells me oh yeah you
might want to install software from
Canon which sounds reasonable because my
printers made by Canon so I click on
this icon Sanko speech would play store
and I can install the can print service
which is nice and faster in Odin because
of our improvements in the install well
everything is done now go back to the
print framework and you can see that I
installed my printer and you can see in
the background it actually found my
printer so wonderful just go ahead and
select my printer no background so now I
was like my printer and my print
partners there so I go ahead and print
this morning will only show up the very
first time you print so it will won't
interrupt further print good process so
everything seems to be fine so let's
check if printing is running so printing
is running so I don't wait adults prints
out takes too long but this is basically
how they use interacts with the printing
the very first time can you close the
video thank you
once the printer setup in a certain way
I'm and you don't have to go through all
the process again you just go say say
print and press the print button so this
is only for the very first time you set
up printing or if you go to a friend and
want to put on their printer and you
might require additional software so the
idea was to make it a very simple for
you to discover which software you need
without having go to replaced or and
searching for something or reading some
documentation
so I hope you've all convinced you to
add printing to your app or maybe you
already edit printing to your app and
you want to improve it over the years we
found certain issues which come up
frequently and I want to go over four of
them and comment on them how do we
suggest to handle them first when you
print you can actually suggest what kind
of attributes the printer is going to
have so in my case I have a portrait
picture of my Android stage right here
and it would be nice if by default the
paper would you orient it in portrait
instead of landscape so if you don't set
anything it might turn up to be by
default in landscape and the users to go
to settings and change it and takes time
away from the user to going back into
your app so I would recommend to suggest
as many of these default attributes as
possible
paper size color mode and this will make
your print experience as smooth as
possible for the user
secondly there's spectacular about the
unload and on right call there's
actually a magic return code from the on
layout call there you can say I actually
go I don't know how many pages the
document has which allows you to return
from your own layout call basically
immediately you can do that and if you
do that you get the UI on the left
especially spinning spinning spinning
and it's not a good - UI because it's
nothing seems to be happening for like
five seconds for the user if you
returned the number of pages you get the
other UI on the on the left side of the
paper
it's a Mac at 17 pages and they use at
least sees that something is going on so
we hire just to implement a layout color
appropriately and return it but in the
case where your layer call would be as
slow as the right call it doesn't make
sense to do it work twice and in this
case we recommend to return unknown
pages third this is a clarification of
the API so let's walk through normal
print process so you issue the print
command
and the pre preview opens and then for
example the user resizes the application
with multi window mode or rotates the
screen so what happens in a common case
is that they go through a non destroy on
great cycle and you could even say if
you rotate the screen the application
after the rotation might look very
different than your original
applications so let's go destroy on
create so on create you have to decide
that's printing still makes sense and
this is situation in this case you don't
do anything and if it doesn't make sense
you don't do anything if it doesn't make
sense you actually have to restart the
printing process by calling by calling
print again last thing I want to mention
is more a plea for my side if you render
PDF please provide valid PDF pride valid
PDF that's match the attributes and that
match the metadata you're sent if you
don't do this it might render fine on
the print preview screen but it might
not render fine inside of your printer
and you might end up with results which
confuse the user it's so many cases
where this didn't work very well so
would be nice if you take care of that
thanks for coming to this talk I put the
Augmented or web page on the slide also
our partners web page so please look at
them and I hope it helps you video
development so I would like to I would
like to invite Sweatt back on stage and
also I'm very happy that our partners
from zero HP and Canon which are all
part of the Mowbray Alliance would come
on stage and you can ask questions
microphone assemble
my name is mingle I work for
hewlett-packard we'll focus on mobile
printing start with the mobile apps and
then walk on KitKat with Chevette
enabling that now walking wisdom sumo
Priya I am Jeremy writes I work for
Xerox and development manager for our
mobile and cloud print offerings really
excited about the improvements coming
out in n today and working with Google
further I am Peter Poirier I'm the
manager for the mobile app development
from Canon I work out of the Seattle
area and I'm also really happy to be
working with spent and Zack and Phillip
on the Google printing improvements for
n which are looking really great
I'm spec I work on the android framework
team I was the initial engineer working
on printing and and now Philips taking
care of that are there any questions no
questions
oh yeah over there one person wonderful
there are gonna be any future plans
within the framework to streamline that
process I mean you showed how you have
to go to the Play Store and download
these plugins and processes is that ever
gonna be baked into the android
framework so that that just happens
transparently in the background the user
doesn't have to worry about it I'm not
sure it's a good idea to install
software for the user without the user
knowing but of course we're always
working to improve the user experience
so if you have suggestions right on this
basis page or we're happy to improve it
because know if you want to you won't
use it to print we want to use it to get
into your app as quickly as possible
back so
and that's actually a very good question
so actually doing kind of fun posts way
for the u.s. discover it's more like a
long tail so you have some printer which
is kind of a special it can pick it up
with the right driver right but we also
have is trying to preload more Priya
plugging all these major phones so we
start with while we I think Amazon has
our product so whenever you have a phone
most likely the moped plug-in will be
pre-loaded so that I avoid on the
additional standard install so we do
both yeah good question thank you
can I just chime in real quick quick
related to that so in N we actually ship
in a printer discovery component that is
part of a platform that is updatable
separately if we need to and it's
actually looking the local network to
find printers for certain manufacturers
any suggest oft where which is how if
you remember Philips demo it recommended
the Canon print plugin to software I
agree that you know easy still have to
go to a couple of Hoops to click the
install button but it's something we
definitely want to improve more hello my
question is concerned the thermal
printer support in the platform the
support for desk jets or you know big
printers are quite okay quite easy to
use and so on but are you do you have
anything in the roadmap to support the
small printers like stores when you're
pretty receipt it's completely different
how the framework should work to this
and I don't see I use it already but
with proper proprietary protocols to
print I wonder if there is any plan to
incorporate this in the framework so
that we have we can use the same
extractor and platform to print and
disturb all printers
right so actually a very good question
again it's really to the vendor who
provides a simple printer to drive the
plug-in and then I think what may be
additional is the paper size right so
it's a special paper right but the
architecture accommodated all that
that's the beauty of the angel
architecture and what and I'll just
build on that I mean one of the things
that million liance is trying to do is
standardize any printer company even
receive printers they could join the
Alliance implement our same standards
and it work with with our technology
that we're releasing but does Xerox HP
or Kenya do you have this printers for
stores like this as far as I know you
don't have it right any plans so
actually it will be really happy to we
the framework team the Android team will
be really happy to work with you guys to
come to see what's missing in the api's
because I can see this printers are
different you have a role and then you
have it's completely different but
probably the announcement of the api's
are not that huge we need to make but we
need to we're not domain experts we need
your help please get in touch with us
help us help you okay thank you my
question is what about support for
before API 19 which is use the old cloud
print or well I can answer I can say
that before API 19 where it's the same
same yeah before I mean the API is
reintroduced in KitKat so you know if
you want to add print into your app for
backwards compatibility you
unfortunately have to fall back to the
old approach you just check the API
level of device you're running in okay
and then fall back to the throw over the
wall approach where you just use the
share intent unfortunately that's the
only way we we looped into back part in
the premium work but it just doesn't
it's not feasible to all devices
I have a question does this framework
extend to Chrome OS as well and are you
writing Chrome apps as these drivers so
we're working with them and it's not all
completely finalized how we're gonna do
but we are of course committed to
bringing printing to Chrome OS and as
good as possible and also bringing
Android on Chrome OS apps they should
print too and you're gonna make this
work of course Thanks yeah just to build
on that a little bit so chrome actually
has print api's they're not the same as
are in Android but they are available
and they have a similar life cycle where
the user selects file print you get an
event you can then respond to that with
the printers that your chrome app
supports and you can run discovery and
do whatever you need to do there it
could be standardized it's using the
same things that we're using here and
then beyond that is getting capabilities
the accepting the print content and then
tracking status
so all those api's and hooks are there
for a chrome app that you can build a
can tie into the native file print path
a chrome printers are not cloud ready
and they they want to print directly
through the driver instead of going
through Google Cloud Print so for those
use cases it will be useful to have a
chrome app as absolutely and in fact
that's kind of what I was referring to
the api's I'm talking about they don't
leverage the GCP path so you can do a
direct print and not go through Google
Cloud Print infrastructure using those
API is that Chrome provided that they I
think they were released last year
sometime so but they are there and I
guess if you have questions after I can
talk more about that actually there's a
name for that API I think they just
released last year's called printer
provider API you can actually write a
chrome laughs interact with there for
printing but there's more coming I
suppose way sure because we just heard
announcement I think the probably that's
what you allude to yesterday that now
that they have a plan to run all in your
apps and
I don't know how that works but
something is coming it's not enough if
they plug in if you if the plug in
concept was totally clear wait and what
Philip had shown was the with a canon
plug-in being installed so each vendor
can write a plug-in so it's up to the
printer companies to provide that and
then with that in place you don't need
the you don't need the GCP path you can
print through these plugins and it will
translate to what the printer needs and
there's also a map riah plugin which is
more Universal so any printer from any
vendor that supports them Oprea print
architecture will work with the same
plugin ok that makes sense
thank you
this is this is perhaps out of the scope
of the current talk but are there any
plans for a 3d printing support well in
the typical you know style of Google
answering this question is will look
into it yeah we don't talk about future
plans honestly yes sorry how can I make
a screen print without save us image so
you want to print out whatever for the
screen without saving it anywhere yeah I
would like to his screen print out
status screen save us image well you can
of course you can take a screenshot and
then in photos select screenshot and
then print of course it gets temporarily
stored on your device if that is to
security sensitive yeah
not directly
you've done some study and you said 95%
of the people you know I want to use
this API right have you done any study
like in the retail space what use key is
you know renting would be like useful so
maybe before I answer that question I
think I would like to just know maybe
summarize what we have discussed today I
think you're the app developers I think
the talk really is one of the single
emphasizes when you write an app that
prints most likely the printer that you
have will be supported that's the key
thing right to your question in terms of
the mobile printing and use case I think
we still see a lot of photo printing a
big part of is photo printing as in your
move to work relativity focus I think
you will have more document as you go to
enterprise there's more Enterprise
related information that can be printed
and we see lots of that just to chime in
for printing what is important I mean
it's like any feature is what is the
value I'm getting for adding this
feature and the other is what's the
price I need to pay in terms of how long
it's gonna take me to develop it so we
we tried really hard to make the entry
point like developing the feature easier
so if you use the helpers to print
bitmap or HTML it's pretty easy but in
case you need some other helpers we'll
be happy to provide that to make the
entry point easier because I think with
enterprise becoming more and more
important for mobile devices
I think printing will definitely but
that's my personal feeling is that will
it'll be get more and more views in the
future so
taking your boarding pass example of
beginning to the logical conclusion and
given androidwear 2.0 being more
independent of the of the phone is there
plans to be able to do things like print
boarding passes directly from your watch
in interior there is not so I don't know
whether the clockwork team is is gonna
turn the feature on its literal each one
feature its configuration when you flash
your Android device I don't see the
reason not to honestly there is nothing
preventing them from doing that in a
sense that the device gets Wi-Fi it it
can run it runs the whole stack so it's
that's that's actually gonna be magical
this will be magical you just print from
your watch yeah yeah thanks yep so thank
you all for coming
I'll gonna be on the spaces page for the
next two or three hours so if you have
questions that's posted there and we can
discuss it there yeah thank you